whew at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Timothy Leary
John Lennon Abbie Hoffman the doors and
Haight Ashbury Perry miles chronicles
the late 60s in his new book hippie this
talk is 45 minutes the last time I was
in I think the last time I was in
Washington was where back in the early
70s were in every few weeks we would
come down here in coaches and get gassed
by the National Guard and go back and
look for ourselves in the papers so I'm
not really at all familiar with there
was where I am I must admit so as you
can probably tell I'm not working from a
script or or doing a reading or anything
like that what I normally do in these
kind of things is run through what I'm
what I was trying to do with the book
and then open it up to the audience
really because to me that it's such a
big subject there's no point in me
rabbiting on about one particular area
of it if if that's not what people are
interested in so I would very much like
people to join in and discuss something
if they're if they want to I mean it
says on the sign that it's a discussion
rather than a lecture or anything my
involvement with the with the 60s was
well from the English and obviously I I
first got involved I think through The
Beat Generation there's a there's a
quite a strong mother there's a very
central lineage running way back to the
40s really of these kind of ideas and I
did notions of sort of liberation of
sexual freedom of well rebellion against
the authorities I guess there was a
slogan in the 60s if never trust anyone
over 30 but when you look at it pretty
much all of the people that they trusted
and discussed and whose ideas were
important to them we're way beyond 30 I
mean Alan Ginsberg actually Alan
Ginsberg was still in his early 30s in
the beginning of the 60s but William
Burroughs Timothy Leary
people like mark Uzi and all the
political thinkers the architects people
like Buckminster Fuller all of these
people were from a previous generation
the real central core of hippy
philosophy as it were as practiced in
San Francisco anyway pretty much was a
Beat Generation well people like Michael
McClure Richard Brautigan Allen Ginsberg
being there a lot Lawrence Ferlinghetti
these people were central to the to the
development of a set of ideas that I'm I
was trying to chronicle here I'm using
hippy pretty much as a catch-all phrase
or fray or word for a whole movement it
really should have been called as a
counterculture or something like that or
the underground because hippy is a bit
too specific it's a so stereotype word
that if you use the word hippy it means
some some guy with a headband and maybe
a refractive lens stuck on his forehead
and you tell instantly what his Twitter
scene music is going to be he's probably
a vegetarian or she is you know he's got
certain views about drugs and/or the
rest of it so this book is not just
restricted to that it's it's it's
supposed to be as a reference book
starting from 65 running through 72 of
all of the counter cultural movements
that were going on not just here in the
States but in Britain and to a certain
extent in in Paris and Amsterdam and
Berlin and a few other places as well
it's very much a Western European and
American movement that that ran over
about a five or six year period and did
I think I sure in a tremendous number of
important new ideas and in a very very
short time which is why it's still even
now quite significant I remember back in
1959 I went to art college in Britain
and when I when we got there one of the
things we would do sit around and talk
about the 20s and have fantastic Paris
was in the twenties with Picasso and
Gertrude Stein and
and you know all these people James
Joyce hanging out with Sylvia beech and
in her book shop and of course that was
3540 years earlier and now the same
thing is occurring and particularly in
Britain and I'm not sure over here since
I don't live here but the 60s have taken
on a sort of mythological sort of status
in which people have all kinds of
strange ideas about what happened then
and what was significant and what was
not and in many ways that's ok because
it means we can take out the good things
and ignore the rubbish but most of it
was it was pretty boring really but we
didn't really we didn't realize we were
living in the sixties I mean no one
thinks in terms of decades you don't
walk around thinking you're you're
living in they whatever these are now
the author saw something so at that time
we weren't really aware of it but only
in retrospect does it seem as if in the
in the 20th century there were the twos
or key periods well one in the 20s and
one in the sixties where a whole lot of
new ideas were brought up and new
experiments in livin' were conducted and
ideas thrown around and a lot of a lot
of mistakes made but nonetheless it
maybe provided a lot of new ways of
living which entered the culture I think
if you look back on the impact of the
sixties on on the way we live now an
awful lot of things did get absorbed I
think obviously the women's movement had
its origins in the 60s the gay
liberation movement the Black Power
movement the ecology movement
I remember in 67 there was a big
conference in London called the
dialectics of liberation when Gregory
Bateson the guy who wrote about dolphin
languages gave a big speech about the
forthcoming global warming problem and
pointing out that it would take 25 to 30
years before it really impacted and I
remember there's the times and a few
other newspapers just simply dismissed
him as a complete crack and yet many of
those ideas have now been taken on wood
and we're certainly seeing the
global warming he was right and in many
many other areas things that you don't
even think about have entered society
for instance in the sixties if you walk
past a construction site and you had
long hair you'd have you know you'd be
jeered at things would be thrown at you
now you will past a construction site
the guys there have got hair down to
their waist and they're covered in
tattoos and you know it's their day are
these sort of modern hippies in many
ways at least again in England I'm not
sure here I think they aren't here too
in New York I've seen guys who thirty
years earlier would have been in a rock
band who were you know working another
area of course was is the the attitude
towards drugs which in the beginning of
the 60s was regarded as very very well
scary I guess and I think whatever one's
attitude towards them and their use and
their legality goes people certainly
know a lot more about them now and I
think after a series of pretty
disastrous experiments that some people
made they have become part of life and
now I understood and people can use them
when out or and choose but choose
whether they want to you to be part of
their lives or not I mean then in the
60s they they were seen as a very
liberating thing and when the Beatles
first took part for instance Paul
McCartney wrote a song called gotta get
you into my life which was written about
part it wasn't about a woman it was an
anthem to marijuana and after being
turned on over here by by Bob Dylan who
became a big influence on them music of
course is another key thing in the in
the in the sixties the the 60s the the
hippie period as it were from 65 on
which is when rock'n'roll made a big
change from being just pop music sort of
Brill Building Tin Pan Alley
Entertainment and became at least one
strand of it became part of the public
debate as it were ideas would be
proposed and sent out through music
particularly through live concerts but
also even in the songs I mean people
like Dylan where we're giving a message
which had never been heard in popular
music before to the extent of course
that people used to wait avidly for the
new Dylan album and hoped that he was
going to slip him the secret of the
universe and in the grooves there and
new Beatles and stones records would
come out and people would play them
backwards and listen for you know secret
secrets hidden in the tracks and of
course some bandits used to hit hide
secrets in the tracks and I mean or at
least sort of usually a few rude words
or something that was about the extent
of it
The Beatles certainly did the other form
of communication that was unique to that
scene was the underground press which
evolved from from two reasons really for
two reasons the the fact is that mostly
it was the underground papers were
serving a community of people who were
taking illegal drugs and therefore they
were providing information about the
drugs about their uses their dangers
their how to grow them how to not be
busted for them and also it was a period
of the Vietnam War
and so you have another need for a
countercultural news source about how to
escape to Canada to avoid the draft and
not go to the war and news about
activities within the military itself
there were a lot of groups of so
left-wing people in the military and all
of this had found its way to people
through the underground press because
you're not going to read it in the
straight press so you have a community
of people who are united by the fact
that they're taking drugs united by the
fact that they're opposed to the war and
they're also according to where they
were living trying to find a new way of
life there there was a tremendous
element of rebellion I suppose against
the straight lifestyle that they grew up
in in America it was to a certain extent
a reaction to the conformity of 50s and
early 60s American life which was very
very wealthy and
devoted very much to a new car every
year and twin beds and all the rest of
it in Britain it was and then the rest
of Europe it was the opposite we didn't
have teenagers in Europe because no one
had any money in the post-war period so
this was really our teenage period it
was the first time young people had any
money and they used it to to play rock
and roll and - it was also the first
time in Europe went that most of them
were educated beyond the level that
their parents were educated in certainly
my parents were left school at 14 and
most of the people who were involved
with the rock and roll scene in Britain
came out of that same kind of background
that they were educated way beyond
anything that their parents could
understand and therefore found
themselves in a situation where they
were looking for ways of living that no
one could really give them any guidance
for there weren't any models there was
no real guidebook so everyone was out in
limb really trying out new things seeing
how well trying to find out a new way of
living the the existing one just didn't
seem quite right depending on where you
were I mean in France for instance the
the main rebellion was done through
traditional French manners of you know
street fights and big you know shootouts
with the cops and stuff and eventually
turning into them may 68 riots which
closed the whole of France down for
several weeks in Germany at the Free
University of Berlin the students
occupied the the whole of the University
and threw bootleg copies of Bill Hemmer
acts function of the orgasm that they're
not the police I mean these are very
very sixties kind of events and they all
come together somehow in one can just
sum it up so that the counterculture or
a catchphrase like Mike hippy as anyway
as you can see I have anything prepared
here so if anyone has any areas that
they'd like to pursue I
but my experience of the 60s was that it
was very anti feminine I mean there were
the old ladies and the guys ran
everything and it wasn't until we had
some experience first in in civil rights
movement and then coming out of that
that we were we were able to organize
around feminism now do you see any
either positive or negative links
between the counterculture and the
feminist movement of the 70s
well I would say that it it started it
had its genesis in the 60s and then went
through obviously went through a
difficult early period as it were the I
think the very early part of that of the
60s was when the pill was first
introduced and when an awful lot of
women we're able to first of all was the
first time they were even able to admit
that they had a sex drive and or have a
sex life of their own something like
that yeah yeah Germaine Greer is an old
friend of mine and she was very very
proud of the fact that she was a groupie
you know she really saw this as an
expression of her sexuality and she saw
herself as equal to the guys that she
was pulling you know I mean I've seen
her do it and in nightclubs you know
sort of transitional business the
transition or sort of period before you
get the workshops and so on of what 71
or 72 it really started but you didn't
just come out of nowhere it came out of
a lot of well obviously there was there
had to be a tremendous reaction against
the this old lady business that I have
to admit was only over here and they
were that they never used that phrase in
Britain but sure also either radical
political side of love the movement it
was the women were licking their stamps
and putting my doing other [ __ ] work
basically and the guys sat around
talking I mean I went to lots of
meetings in New York with there be
Hoffman and Jerry Rubin and everyone
and but all of the work the actually
flitting and you know running around was
all done by the women and of course it
needed it was any when women themselves
got together and put a stop to all of
that it was likely to happen because the
guys we're not gonna just just walk away
from it it's true yeah seems to me like
remember in the early 60s when we used
to watch movies like the Frankie Avalon
Annette Funicello of beach movies it
seems like there was a youth culture
that was developing then but there was a
discontinuity introduced by the Vietnam
War where everything suddenly became
radicalized within say from between
certainly 64 and 68 and it was like
Vietnam was the center of the entire
world and actually didn't start to get
normalized until after the u.s. withdrew
from Vietnam and it started to die down
I think that's true yeah I think that
that war was very very divisive and made
put a lot of people into a position
where they were leading in an illegal
life almost I mean they would they were
separated out from regular society by
their opposition it was I don't know it
really hotted up I guess in the very
early seventies that was when when the
real huge demonstrations were occurring
but it always been an opposition to the
war from from way back like you say and
he only did grow and grow and and
obviously helped by by the growth of a
more serious sort of youth culture
rather than you know bubblegum music you
had the Beatles and the stones and Bob
Dylan and so on well yeah I still
remember people who burned their draft
cards and stuff were kind of looked at
as I look look at askance in six
six but some tarry sometime between
sometime during 67 there was a snap
where popular opinions started to really
pile against that war it was kind of
like well we have to do or do you
support the president and somehow I go
to Johnson administration well maybe not
even that maybe
maybe right at the end there at the end
of the Johnson administration something
something snapped yeah yeah became a
really really widespread business and
also that was when you started to have
underground newspapers produced within
the military itself and the whole thing
just just grew and grew into a mass
movement I mean that that was it was
curious right across the world you have
up you had a political period then I
mean that was the time of the 68 riots
in in France of course which began on
student campuses and very rapidly spread
to the to the unions and the car
factories and they did closed the whole
country down I remember driving back
from the South of France in May 68 and
all the freeways were manned by strikers
who were just they docufide all of the
pole tollbooths and just had big tubs of
for you to throw donations into but they
also have like you know liters and
liters of wine and we're encouraging
people to stop and have a drink with
them so it was really dangerous business
driving around also you couldn't get gas
because the the total oil refinery on
their own had a big red flag flying from
it and it was completely shut down and
they closed all shipping on their own as
well with barges so you couldn't get gas
anywhere you had to maybe drive for
about a half a tank and then go off into
the country and try and find a farmer
it's only so took about five days to get
so get back to Kelly or during the mid
70s when you started to have the hippy
movement kind of establishment ties
before using it for advertising purposes
well yes I mean this is the problem in
the whole hippie thing sort of got
co-opted I mean it was really that that
my interest is really the time when new
ideas were being in any in England you
have people like Richard Branson and so
on who basically he was a classic
example of a hip capitalist who would
have started off selling posters in you
know Haight Ashbury or something I mean
now in South of England you know he's
got an Airlines railroad license I mean
record shops all over the world yeah
the early sixties in this country
don't think existed in Britain first one
of these was a civil liberties issue
because of our First Amendment and the
curtailment of rights that had occurred
during the anti-communist drives of the
40s and 50s there was there was a
rebellion against the beginning in the
beginning at least in 1960 and the
second was the civil rights movement
which really set the tone and shaped the
ideas of the 60s movements in this
country every 60s movement is a child of
the civil rights movement here you're
right in Brittany grew out of the
campaign funicula disarmament pretty
much which was the CND know you know
that peace sign that originated in
oxford at the combined Universe to CND
group I forget the guy who designed it
but that became a very radicalizing
force in Britain because it was the
first time an awful lot of young people
had ever left home and every year at
Easter they had these big marches that
would go from elder must a nuclear base
of nuclear weapons research facility
they would march to London it took four
days and they would open up all the
schools and town halls and you know you
would sleep under the floor you know
into the tables and pubs and stuff it
was by the time they got to London there
were hundreds of thousands of people
there not entirely kids though I mean
you couldn't really say it was just a
countercultural thing but they began in
59 and it was mainly a thing from the
early 60s but it's still going on
actually I think there was one last
Easter but it's not a buddy everything
has changed since then but but that was
the really key period that was when
Bertrand Russell and founded something
called the committee of a hundred and
they practice civil disobedience and
would try and break into government safe
houses and all kinds of stuff and
finishing up with Biz Lord Russell being
carried off you know and protesting them
yeah draft figure into you know the
counterculture in this country I would
think the opposition of Vietnam or in
overseas was radically different than it
was here oh yeah
no no other no known European country
was sending troops so obviously it was
very different
no here I think it was it was absolutely
crucial and more and more so as more
people got called up and more and more
people came home in body bags no it was
like like the civil rights movement it
was another uniquely American aspect of
it to the thing but it also extends sort
of out beyond what I would call the
counterculture I mean that and the civil
rights movement our mass movements which
not really counter at all I mean I think
the that was what was so wonderful about
them is that they they were spontaneous
movements from the hope public the
people really again a lot of things that
you have in your book came out of that
as well as frienldy yeah yeah it's not a
cut and dry thing it's everything is
influencing each other and one thing is
causing another one and learning from it
and so on it was yeah national
improvement of a win maybe in the mid to
late seventies there was a wonderful
cover it's a man looking in the mirror
on one side he's a hippie it was falling
along hairs and beads and the other side
of the mirror we self America he's this
very respectable well-dressed person and
the expression is exactly the same and
utter appalled this the heaviest
appalled that us well dress personally
respect persons that would come they're
respectable
you know society in south assist
appalled me if he was I was wonder which
of these two figures are both or you may
hear go on before so very respectable
looking
yeah so are you both these figures or
what is your connection
Mike's my connection is is that I was
the publisher of the first underground
paper in Europe called International
times and I also was the co-owner of a
bookshop an art gallery called indica
which is which was backed by the Beatles
so my connection was through rock and
roll really it was where John and John
met Yoko and all that kind of stuff so
yes it was really really through a close
involvement with the underground press
and and because of because I had a
bookshop I was involved with many of the
people over here from 65 on which for
instance I knew ed Sanders and Ken
Weaver from the Fugs who were one of
those a sort of radical folk rock combo
from the from New York very strong anti
war stuff it Sounders also had a
bookshop in New York called the psi
where he published a lot of mimeograph
poetry and so on and he used to send
over big boxes of that stuff to England
and we would send back used penguins and
whatever stuff was being published in on
drugs or whatever that you know in
Britain also that my connection was
through Allen Ginsberg who through a
bookshop I was managing in 65 in in
London Allen came into the store with it
because they'd sounders had suggested he
he'd looked me up and he needed some
place to live so he stayed with me in 65
and that was when we put on a big poetry
reading at the Albert Hall and it was
really the big poetry reading in the
Albert Hall which also featured Gregory
Corso and Lawrence Ferlinghetti that we
realized the sort of the the size of the
constituency for a sort of new for some
kind of youth movement because there
were 7,000 people there in the Opera
House this huge round aureum these boxes
three or four tiers of boxes including
the Royal Box and every one was every
box was filled with people there's a
bunch of people having a party they had
wine and I was pot smoke floating around
and the very center of the orbit who was
a big round space where the boxing rink
is sometimes they used to hold
tournaments there and are delaying the
countercultural psychiatrist country
Socratic anti psychiatrist he used to
call himself brought a lot of his
patients along so they were all dancing
to music that only they could hear and
people like Indira Gandhi were in the
audience and people from the Cuban
embassy I mean all sorts of everything
was all mixed up it was it was pretty
good and as a felon Getty and Ginsburg
and everybody read but he wasn't really
the reading so much as the fact that it
was like a big party we recognized that
there were an awful lot more of us than
we thought you know really I'm more of
an old beatnik I think you know because
you know the more recent thing and I
started off as an art student in 59 I
went to art college and art college in
Britain was a an excuse to spend four
years just hanging out I'm smoking pot
really and doing a few paintings and
most of the people who had any kind of
success he went through British art
colleges when became rock and roll
musicians you know everybody from Eric
Clapton to David Bowie to John Lennon
right on through there even Rod Stewart
I think some of them anyway most of them
went through art college having read
several of your books which if folks are
interested in this they haven't nobody's
mentioned your other books oh that's
because it's not published you know no
no not the new one but the Beatles and
the other ones I think your something
like an anthropologist in that you are a
part of the scene and you fit but you
also are an observer and
the books come out of the very
interesting notes that you've made
during that time after the events there
isn't there is an element to that yes
and I did a book about a year ago you're
in a half of a chord in the 60s which
was actually my sort of personal memoirs
but it was since no one has ever heard
of me I used it as a way of telling the
the story of the English underground but
using anecdotes from my experience but I
have written books on the Paul McCartney
book is very much to do with his
involvement with with my bookshop and
he's also his involvement with
avant-garde activities in Britain and
political activities and so on because
the Beatles were other they were the
most commercial band on earth they were
also sort of underground hippie band in
many respects they they spanned the
decade perfectly I mean they began in
1960 they and ended in at the end of 69
they started off in black and white and
ended in very much full color they
started off with their suits and ties
write really nice little mop tops and
finished up a sort of Lords of
psychedelia or something and you know
John seeing colours everywhere but yeah
so I think Valerie is probably right I
am a bit of a psycho so Christopher
Isherwood situation I mean he wasn't he
wrote I am a camera and everything but
he was also very central to that scene
in Berlin I wouldn't like to compare
myself with him too much but it is that
same I think me anyway to really survive
actually is for me was to keep a certain
distance we also had a an underground
club for instance could the UFO Club
which had as its housebound the Pink
Floyd and the Syd Barrett who was the
lead singer and writer for the Pink
Floyd in the early days he burned
himself that totally on a SCID it was
very easy giving the peer pressure in
those days to [ __ ] out was you know it
was quite stir home
yeah was it difficult writing a
biography of Allen Ginsberg no or could
you compare to what it was like writing
a biography of Kerouac Ginsberg the well
I did a book on Kerouac and on Ginsburg
the I never knew I never met Kerouac and
it was also a book that I'd been
commissioned to do as an introduction to
his work it wasn't a full-length
biography they didn't pay me enough to
spend years and years on it either I
mean the only way to write a full-length
biography is to be able to take at least
two years maybe more
whereas I got a very good advance on the
on the Ginsberg one and it took about
four years to do I knew Allen really
well he used to always stay with me when
he came to Britain and when I first came
to the States I would usually stay with
him although then later on I used to
sublet an apartment for two or three
years at a time but um he remained a
very close friend and when I when the
time came to do this book he gave me
complete carte blanche to look at every
single he found his private journals
going back to 1941 he agreed to read
through it but also insisted he insisted
that he never that I shouldn't even
listen if he tried to change anything
you know it was he was such a believer
in freedom and and recognized that of
course whatever you're writing in a
biography it's only one view you know if
I write his last life story that's only
my view of it inevitably somebody else
writing one would would give a very very
different picture and it worked out
pretty well it was hard because Ellen
was a workaholic and at the time I was
working on the book he went off to China
and he went all over than Eastern Europe
I mean he was just everywhere except in
New York which is where I'd moved to in
order to write a tenth but yes so
eventually I finished that I decided I
would just travel with him everywhere so
I would you know go with him in the cab
up to see his dentist and then we would
take the bus over to Patterson to see
his stepmother and everywhere we went I
had a tape
could and in the end I remember he he
just we were walking down Fifth Avenue I
think and he grabbed his head and he
said your deprogramming
and I think but all those tapes are now
in New York Public Library so you know
at least he didn't have to do that with
anybody else after me yeah sure yeah
he's gonna say kind of a footnote to
Jack Kerouac the when I left Lowell they
were thinking about commissioning a
statue to him as the local boy who
became famous and all and they did yeah
yes a huge thing called the
commemorative which I always thought was
an adjective I mean it's in the paper
that he'd be turning in his grave to be
the focus of such a push why activity is
enormous thing it looks like a war
memorial though it's just series of big
you know carved granite plucks Flint's
whatever you thought of I don't know
what you call it
someone should put on all the names you
should be curved in it actually it's got
extras from his books they took him a
while to find extracts that didn't
mention drugs or sex or anything because
I think the received you know the
opinion in in Lola it stood that he you
know he was a good Catholic boy who you
know didn't take drugs and didn't do
anything at all just happened to be as a
really famous writer from law you know
like on that you've deprogrammed me yeah
what's your definite notice the title
hippie
isn't really indicative of the book in
one sense because it covers so much
ground so what's your definition of a
hippie who is one and rather who was
mine it wasn't well I think it was to be
quite honest a real genuine if he was
completely hedonistic person very not
really the part of the counterculture in
terms of supporting society putting the
building of a new society or a new
community I think a real sort of down
and out hippie was was pretty much sat
around at home smoking dope and not
really contributing much to anywhere but
as I say I've tried to use the word much
much more widely than that because I
think you could also say that hippies
were in fact the people who were
experimenting the different communal
types of living I mean I remember when I
was in Berkeley in 71 with Allen
Ginsberg and my girlfriend and mice and
and Allen and myself had a floor in a
hippie commune in in Berkeley where I
mean half the people who came down to
dinner we were naked and there were
ducks and stuff walking around but with
Allen I once visited and a really
serious commune in Berkeley where there
were about thirty people living there
you know in a house with no doors on any
of the rooms and everything was shared
there would be cardboard boxes you know
it just said small Underpants big
Underpants and t-shirts and it was a
really radical experiment and I don't
suppose it lasted very long and to me
though that is that was one of the best
aspects of the hippie scene was that
people were trying out new models of
living and a lot of them well most of
them didn't work but at least they tried
them and and we've gained from the
experience I think I mean there were a
huge number of communes at one point
doing thousands of them up in the
mountains
usually there's still some in Britain
actually in up in Wales you get every
time there's a sort of festival all
these old hippies sort of come out of
the hills with mongrel dogs on the end
of a bit of bale twine you know sort of
woolly hats and yes
I was in Berkeley in the early 60s and
there really wasn't much of a
counterculture the beats were sort of
over there I think the community began
expanded about 65 yeah and what I saw
was something about that urgent between
module called hippies but I'll take a
slightly broader term people who were
into feeling good doing their own thing
and the serious politico's who were into
making social change and fighting the
war and bringing a buffalo his
liberation and holler is certainly a
little bit of blending and overlap it's
almost as though you had to choose path
you know it was very much the same in
Britain because the left there was so
divided up into different types of you
know the Fourth International and the
straight Trotskyists and the you know
all the different subgroups and they all
had their own publications and I spent
most their time arguing with each other
it was but then then they discovered
rock and roll I remember when the guys
from new left review suddenly found that
they were liking music that was
politically totally incorrect
you know like Jagger singing about you
know who wants yesterday's papers who
wants yesterday's girl and everything it
was a subject of a huge long essay and
you left review about why was it that
you nobody's utterly unacceptable views
were also very good music and net was in
about 64 I guess when that record came
out and it was part of the dynamic of
you know the public discussion going on
none of it was cut and dried at all and
none of it was ever resolved but but
you're right I mean there was there was
always a division between the sort of
political thinkers really and the guys
who just wanted to sit around and smoked
out the very rarely did those two meet
except maybe in John Lennon I think when
his brief period when he was fated by by
Abbie Hoffman and Jerry Rubin and by
Robin Blackburn and the Fourth
International in London actually they
were the first people who try to get
Lennon on board
sixty-eight
we did yes
yeah actually the 68 convention though
he felt that that he'd been lied to
because afterwards Abbie Hoffman and
Jerry Rubin said that they had expected
and intended it to turn into a bloodbath
and that they really wanted the American
population to see bunch of hippies being
bashed on ahead by by the police
where's Allen had been conned into
thinking that if he went along and armed
and and made it into a sort of Peace
Festival then he would be able to calm
the situation and to a certain extent he
did I mean he was went during one of the
police riots in I forget which Park it
was in Chicago he actually chanted on
for eight hours I mean and eventually he
had like a thousand people sitting
around him also bombing and nothing
happened to that particular group
bilborough's started off with him it
soon realized that this wasn't no place
for him
yeah I was reminded by a story from
someone who came back from Vietnam about
your tax dollars at work and it seems
the North Vietnamese would play all of
the latest rock songs because there's a
lot of anti-war and whatever in them and
what they got over American radio was
heavily censored so what the US did was
they set up jamming towers to block the
North Vietnamese radio signals and what
the Marines that this guy used to be in
would do would call in airstrikes
against the towers really yeah I could
hear the uncensored version a lot of
those tapes came from WPIX in which was
done in in New York I'm not sure how
much of all that is is known but I had
an English hour on radio Hanoi at that
point um just just from records being
sent to me you know that I just made a
tape of and gave them to a certain
person and they somehow went off to
Hanoi yeah I forgot about that
yeah what what do you think well what do
you think about the idea that history
has been sort of rewritten or or it
seems like people have forgotten what it
was like before the 60s came along how
Stella fine the 50s were you know you
know practically the typical military
like in the junior High's you know we
were out there marching and that's right
you had officers cooler and everything
in ROTC was it could well that that was
later on in college I mean even in
junior high we were doing some
military drills but but you know the
hippy movement now has such a bad
reputation among so many people but
they've forgotten what the hippies were
rebelling against and like you were
saying so many things have changed since
the sixties and people have forgot that
- yeah yeah no it's been a fundamental
change I mean obviously I know more
about what happened in in Britain but I
remember at the beginning of the sixties
in Britain for instance unmarried
mothers had to live in sort of hostels
and stuff if they weren't doing with
their parents you know because this was
so unspeakable that someone should be
married you know not married and have a
child that they there was no way they
could ever rent a place or anything I
mean it was you know all that kind of
thing is has changed so totally you know
in Britain's probably got more unmarried
mothers than any other nation I should
think it right these days so certainly
in Europe anyway it only and it's not
regarded as the problem either over here
I think the fundamentalist sort of right
Christian Right do see everything evil
that is in you know cut stems from the
60s pretty much the breakdown of of the
family the slackening of the hold of the
church and all the rest of it does yeah
it probably does stem from us it is our
fault
you know maybe it's your phone yes yes
as an anthropologist what's your take on
the 1980s because it seems to me like
like the Conservatives tried to it's
like a chiropractor straightening up a
bent spine going the other way only they
didn't quite get it right it was like
almost everything that happened in the
Reagan years was to undo what had
happened during the 60s yeah I mean - in
a very simplistic way I mean I think
it's really the that was the triumph of
greed of
and any kind of sense of commonality I
think the one good thing that did come
out of the sixties on a mass social
level like that was concern for the for
the environment a concern for other
people I mean I guess there was even a
movement towards a national health
system over here I mean which in America
is still the only industrial country
that doesn't have one but all of those
things were sort of swept away by this
incredible cult of the individual and
rather than than the community and and
the idea that greed was good basically
which is what Regan sort of stood for
and and which of course such a stood for
as well you know his big mate you know
and she managed to do equal damage in
Britain
yeah all of its offshoots sort of went
right on without a context they did yeah
yeah well he got taken over by the big
corporations and they're in Arabic the
rock-and-roll bands got very greedy
I mean they were embraced by kids to set
to a degree in terms of let's say
starting with Punk and going to rap and
punk was a genuine to almost like the
end of the 60s you know I would you can
have it you could have a sort of a long
view of punk the 60s culture beginning
in about 65 and ending in in about 1980
certainly in Britain punk was had the
same sensibility I mean they used to
instead of underground newspapers they
used to do
Xerox magazines and there were hundreds
of them at one point it was about 120 of
them coming out and they were all really
amusing and good I mean there was one
from one of the London suburbs called a
pasty in Ilford and you know though in
sniffing glue and all these kind of
magazines there and they were just
distributed for free or for a couple of
pence you know some it wasn't it was a
return to that sense of just sharing
information and an old information
should be free and they took it to an
extreme beyond anything in the 60s you
know they believed you could have a
rockin Robin and that even to play to
even know how to play your instrument
was regarded as sort of elitist somehow
but and then since then the rock'n'roll
to me anyway has become largely so down
sects you know if you don't have good
choreography and you don't get anywhere
yeah it was really the development of
MTV and and the unlived unknown video
that pretty much did for that side of
rock and roll anyway
it's beautifully made a lot of the new
stuff but it has no content as far as
I'm concerned but then I'm too old music
and visualize it for your own self
because you already have videos for it
yeah yeah performance visuals it's just
whatever videos are I don't know I saw
the despair of it really but no mm but
hopefully new things will will keep
coming out I sometimes also think that
there's no way that somebody of my age
could really tell whether there's you
know what what's going on is okay my kid
loves Banquo darkness for instance which
to me looks looks like kiss all over
again you know their lead singer has
dressed up like a chicken and sort of
you know see screeching around him but
they're apparently about to break really
big over here they've cleaned up their
their album they did very very well in
Britain so they've remixed their their
album for America taking out all the
references to heroin and stuff and so
you'll probably be hearing about them
soon yeah so you know one thing I recall
about the 60s that there was there was a
kind of sense of humor in the air a lot
of people had a sense of humor and
whimsy was was everywhere and we've just
completely lost that it seems so many of
the things the Beatles did or that we're
done and you know Greenwich Village or
Haight Ashbury you know it was always
done tongue-in-cheek you know like like
with a twinkle in the eye and like they
were great put on it was just a lot of
gratuitous humor it seems just in the
air and everywhere which I miss a lot
these days
I think you're right yeah that humor is
missing and it was also the humor that
which distinguished often between you
know where the music was coming from it
in England it tended to be very much
about dancing gnomes and stuff you know
very sort of women stupid whimsical
Victorian imagery quite often a lot of
it over here with probably rather more
pot induced I suspect but but not
necessarily a lot of like you say though
a lot of stuff from San Francisco is
very funny you know they were there was
some yeah yeah I know the the
underground press was filled with
wonderful jokes I mean and of course in
addition to the underground newspapers
you have underground cartoons you know
the the best example of which being The
Simpsons which came out of the
underground comics and finally finished
up on on the screen and it as far as I'm
concerned it's still one of the most
subversive things coming out of America
it's absolutely wonderful particularly
only Europeans adore it it's on every
day in France customs strangely
something not something I'd dubbed you
know are we done yeah Thank You Barry
miles is the author of biographies on
William Burroughs Allen Ginsberg Jack
Kerouac and former Beatle Paul McCartney
hippy is published by Sterling visit
sterling pub comm for more information